[Music]
good morning it is seven o'clock this is
sky news breakfast there will be plenty
for boris johnson and joe biden
to discuss later in cornwall ahead of
the g7 summit
as the u.s president begins his first
overseas visit
there's the resumption of transatlantic
travel trade security
and of course sausage wars the row over
the northern ireland brexit arrangements
we'll speak to the international trade
minister greg hans in just
a few minutes also this morning if
cornwall is
too busy and too expensive then could
wild camping be the answer
we'll be discussing that with the father
and son who've traveled across britain
pitching their tents for free also
coming up
he's on the floor so have a peep over
the hedge
let's go around at some shape
jeremy clarkson takes a break from fast
cars to run his
own farm for a new tv series he'll be
chatting with us about how he cope with
brexit
climate change and coronavirus it is
thursday the 10th of june
tough talking president biden set to
raise the northern ireland brexit deal
with
the pm along with trades travel and
climate change ahead of the g7 summit
we're going to make it clear that the
united states is
back and democracies of the world are
standing together
to tackle the toughest challenges and
the issues that matter most to our
future
[Music]
at the heart of the action cornwall
prepares for global attention and a bit
of a traffic jam
as the g7 leaders arrive
also this morning children sending
explicit pictures
and teachers underprepared the damning
report that's found sexual harassment
is now normalized in british schools
quizzed about coronavirus the health
secretary under scrutiny from mps about
his role
in the government's response to the
pandemic
good morning we have more sunshine to
come today a bit of a great start best
of sunshine will be in the east
staying a little bit cloudy in the west
but again it's warm and it's going to
stay
warm right into the weekend i'll bring
you all the details
later on
and remembering prince phillip the queen
is given a new rose named after the duke
of edinburgh
on what would have been his 100th
birthday
morning all president biden will be
getting
straight down to business when he holds
talks with boris johnson and cornwall
today
ahead of the g7 summit on his first
overseas visit since taking office
president baradin is expected to say the
disputes over the northern ireland
brexit deal
cannot be allowed to put the good friday
agreement at risk
the two leaders will also set out their
joint vision for a new atlantic charter
working closely to recover from the
pandemic our diplomatic editor dominic
wagon reports now from cornwall
he's a president on a mission to rally
america's allies
to tackle some of the greatest threats
the world has faced
landing in cornwall with his words
already ringing in their ears
in suffolk surrounded by the u.s
military joe biden had this
uncompromising message for the alliance
and its rivals at every point along the
way
we're going to make it clear that the
united states is back
and democracies of the world are
standing together
to tackle the toughest challenges and
the issues that matter most to our
future
that we're committed to leading with
strength
defending our values
and delivering for our people this is a
president determined to dispel the
doubts cast by his predecessor
over america's leadership of the world
to tackle this century's most pressing
challenges
we have to do it together we have to end
covet 19 not just at home which we're
doing
but everywhere there's no wall high
enough to keep us safe from this
pandemic
or the next biological threat we face
and there will be others
that requires coordinated multilateral
action
we must all commit to an ambitious
climate action
if we're going to prevent the worst
impacts of climate change limiting
global warming it's taken the president
seven months to get out of america
but the same threat that's kept him at
home will preoccupy him here
he's brought with him a promise to fund
hundreds of millions of covered vaccines
worldwide
america will lead the free world again
say officials
tackling what they call the three seas
covid climate change
and china
ahead of the weekend's g7 summit the
president meets britain's prime minister
who spent the day highlighting the uk's
efforts to reverse climate change
there are points of friction between
president and prime minister
northern ireland in particular but
observers say there's too much at stake
to let any of that get between them this
is a
a pivotal moment where we can either be
working together
to ensure that the future is not along
the lines of china and russia
and if we don't work together then
there's all
likelihood that the world will look very
different in 10
15 20 years face-to-face diplomacy is
back first for the prime minister and
president
then all g7 leaders meeting together a
lot has changed though since they last
met
kovid worsening climate change the rise
of
china it'll take unity and determination
for the west to meet those challenges
head on if it fails rivals and autocrats
are waiting in the wings dominic waghorn
sky news falmouth
pleased to say the minister for trade
policy greg hands jones is on the
program mr hands great to have you on
the program this morning
a busy few days pending at these
presidential visits
always a little bit of glitz and glamour
surrounding them but but at the heart of
it
the announcement of a new atlantic
charter tell us more
well it's 80 years since the original
atlantic charter launched by
churchill and roosevelt uh and that was
all about
the world pulling out world war ii and
recovering and setting a road map
for the world after world war ii this
atlantic charter
is all about recovering from the
pandemic a joint action
by the united states and the united
kingdom particularly in areas of
fighting the pandemic and future
pandemics
working together on climate change
working together on security and cyber
and working together on guaranteeing the
the global
rules-based uh trading system so this is
a big moment for cooperation in between
the united states
and the united kingdom going forward um
as you say
a big emphasis on on transatlantic
cooperation
a big issue at the moment is of course
when we might see flights resuming
between the two countries are we to take
it that we're edging closer to that
point
well we're launching a working group
together the united states and the
united kingdom this is one of the
agreements that
uh prime minister boris johnson and
president joseph biden will be launching
today
we'll be looking at how we can reopen
transatlantic travel between the us and
the uk
uh to be a working group set up and
we're looking as a matter of priority
it's such an
important relationship for travelers
for families for tourists but also for
investors
every day in this country a million
people in this country go to work for us
companies
in the united states more than a million
people go to work for british companies
it's very important that we get that
transatlantic relationship
reset up in terms of travel between the
two countries as well
we also know from uh from reporting that
president biden is set to
to purchase 500 million doses of a
vaccine to be
distributed around the world when do we
think the british government might do
something similar
well look uh the uk government we're a
massive contributor already to the
kovacs program which is the
global response uh to help developing
countries
um get enough vaccines where 500 million
pound
contributor to that from our aid budget
and worth remembering that a third of
all
jobs globally are being provided by the
oxford astrazeneca vaccine
uh which of course is uh is had a big
part of that has been from investment
from the uk government
uh this time a year ago to make sure
that that uh vaccine is up and running
working closely
uh with oxford university and with
astrazeneca so the uk is a massive part
of that solution
can we talk for a second then mr hands
about about the situation which
we know will be discussed between the uk
and the us and that of
the northern ireland protocol and and
perhaps any knock-on effects it might
have in the on the good friday agreement
the front pages of the papers this
morning are reporting the fact
that the united states has issued
something of a diplomatic rebuke
is that the case well look we agree with
the united states we agree with the fact
there should be a negotiation there is a
negotiation between the united kingdom
and the european
and we absolutely agree on preserving
the peace process and the good friday
agreement
uh it's a very important uh thing for
the united states as well don't forget
the united states is a guarantor
of the good friday agreement uh senator
george mitchell who is the u.s
negotiator
is a senate contemporary of joe biden
the us has played a big big role in the
good friday grim we absolutely agree
that preserving the peace in northern
ireland but to do that
does need a more pragmatic approach from
the european union
in terms of how it interprets the
protocol and those what the talks
yesterday uh between lord frost and mary
schefter which were all about
was making sure that the protocol can
work better to preserve the
peace in northern ireland but as i
understand it
at the meeting that took place yesterday
uh between mr sefkovich and
and lord frost lord frost did not rule
out the fact
that rule out the possibility of the uk
unilaterally extending the grace period
for northern ireland in essence lord
frost failed to rule out
knotted hearing to commitments that we
have made in a
treaty well well look at the great
period is a matter of pragmatism you
know when do you actually
uh introduce the new changes it's all
about making sure that businesses and
consumers are ready
it's all about making sure that peace is
preserved in northern ireland we've
submitted some very serious proposals to
brussels
about how to improve the situation uh
talks are ongoing
uh they didn't get a breakthrough
yesterday but nor have they broken down
and exactly as we should be doing we're
talking with the european union trying
to find a pragmatic solution
to these very real issues uh facing uh
consumers and businesses in northern
ireland a very very important part
of that peace process is making sure uh
that people in northern ireland that
their lives are not disrupted
and making sure the businesses are not
disrupted that is a big part of
preserving the peace in northern ireland
but just be absolutely clear you are not
ruling out unilaterally extending the
grace period beyond
beyond the detail as set out in the
protocol well look we're talking
continuing to talk
with the european union uh it is urgent
to find a solution because the current
grace period expires shortly
we need to find that solution and we
need to find something that works well
for everybody
and make sure that uh businesses
consumers in northern ireland
can continue to operate as normally as
possible
i suppose the problem that many people
have is well lord frost said it himself
we underestimated the effect of the
protocol
on good movements to northern ireland
with some suppliers in great britain
simply
not sending their products because of
the paperwork required
he didn't see it coming the problem is
that plenty of other people did
including people operating business in
northern ireland
well look uh i i think let's talk about
where i actually talked about it we're
talking about
you know what is the actual threat um to
uh health in the european union that's
really
what the rules are supposed to be there
these sps checks they're called sanitary
and phyto-sanitary checks they're a big
part of the world trading system
they're there to protect public health
so what he actually
is the threat to public health from
sausages being moved from say birmingham
to belfast to go to
tescos or sainsbury's in northern
ireland what is the threat to public
health uh in the european union that is
foreign
apologies for interrupting but ministers
we once again find ourselves in a
situation in which ministers of the
crown
seem seemingly sanguine about perhaps
acting
unlawfully under our obligations
international treaty
well i disagree this is all about
talking negotiating
to find a more pragmatic approach um
and making sure that we do not disrupt
the lives
of people in northern ireland that is
also a really really important part of
the good friday
sorry apologies to minister why did we
sign it in the first place then
well look it was signed at a difficult
time for everybody
um but we weren't to be honest we were
expecting
a more pragmatic approach from the
european union rather than a
one-size-fits-all
lan as a port is not the same as
rotterdam and the eu
is following a a very officious
interpretation of a lot of these rules
we are looking for
a more pragmatic approach which will
help
businesses consumers in north island
people to continue to have access
to the products that they're expecting
and have had access to for some time
that is the most important thing here is
actually the people of northern ireland
in all of this
um to change topic just just for the
remainder of our interview
mr hands um matt hancock of course the
health secretary
appearing in front of the select
committee a little bit later on today
key questions surround his handling of
of care homes
we know now that by august of last year
there were 30 000
excess deaths in care homes who is
responsible for that
well look the the situation in in care
homes
is an absolute tragic my father died in
the care home uh
last april uh from covid so i know it's
a
first hand ministers there was a lot of
uh
advice from public health england uh in
relation to care homes that i'm sure
will be examined as part of the public
inquiry uh
coming up and i think all of these
questions will need to be answered but i
don't
think it should be laid at the door of
matt hancock
as to as to what happened at that time
but a lot of difficult decisions had to
be made
uh quite quickly last march and last
april but i personally am acutely aware
of the situation
uh mr hands a busy few days ahead for
you i'm sure so we'll let you crack on
thanks very much for joining us
thank you now
sexual harassment online sexual abuse
and sharing
nude photos all becoming normalized
apparently among britain's school
children according to the uk's schools
watchdog ofsted
the organization says that many students
are not reporting this harmful behavior
and has warned that teachers are under
prepared for the scale of sexual abuse
among children our home affairs editor
jason farrell reports aged 15
zan moon was sexually abused by a school
boy at a party
nine years on she's on a mission to stop
it happening to others
and feels schools have a part to play
after sharing her story on instagram she
received dozens of similar testimonies
and since then has been to meet with
headmasters and this week
was invited to the department of
education so i'm going to go in and ask
them to update the curriculum so that we
have sex education as a standalone
subject that boys can be tested on
consent
i think there needs to be more support
and accessibility for victims so that we
can
easily come forward and there needs to
be a rehabilitation program
for the boys and the perpetrators so
that when they offend
they're not just punished but educated
now the school's inspectorate is calling
for similar changes
after its investigation found sexual
harassment was normalized
amongst school children in ofsted's
review 90 percent of girls said that
being sent
unwanted explicit photos or videos
happened either sometimes
or a lot sexist abuse was equally common
and it was often reported that boys
collected nude photos of the girls
and shared them on social media the
ofsted review
recommends that schools assume that
sexual harassment is happening
even if they don't think they have a
problem the main finding we're reporting
is that sexual harassment including
online abuse of young people
is so widespread that most children are
taking it just as
commonplace normal even harmful sexual
activity
and the second finding is that teachers
and leaders in schools and colleges are
just
sadly often not aware of the true extent
of the problem
the founder of everyone's invited the
anonymous reporting website which led to
this review
says all schools can do more to learn
what's going on
we believe that everyone's invited that
there should be
anonymous reporting systems available in
all schools
because we don't feel that we're there
quite yet
that students and young people are
feeling able
to safely share their stories helen pike
is master of magdalen college school in
oxford which was named on everyone's
invited and she welcomed the issue being
exposed
it's a very upsetting experience i think
it was
you know a real moment of realization
and a window
into some elements of
teen life that have been troubling us
for quite some time
but she warns things need to be handled
fairly
as the ofsted report really sensibly
says there is a danger of over
criminalizing children and some quite
unfortunate
demonizing parallels have been drawn
here and
i think we need to look at cultures and
environments
in which young people and you know
particularly boys and the examples
you've given
make unfortunate and sometimes illegal
decisions
the department of education says
teachers will be better supported in the
future to recognize sexual harassment
and abuse
and teach confidentially about issues of
consent
online pornography and healthy
relationships
jason farrell sky news
now cornwall will spend the next few
days at the centre of
international politics and diplomacy as
it of course
hosts the g7 summit very few people who
live there will get to see the leaders
but many will feel the disruption of
such a major event
dan whitehead reports now from cornwall
for cornwall's holidaymakers there are
some unusual sights at the seaside
royal navy ships patrol carbus bay as
police
zoom past on jet skis while on the beach
military radar
scan the skies after months of
preparation
thousands of delegates journalists and
police are here
as the g7 summit begins are you ready
yes we are ready we've been planning
this for months now
it's the biggest police and security
event in england this year
so as you can imagine we have big
numbers to help us police this
six and a half thousand officers have
come to cornwall from every force
in the country a thousand are having to
stay on a cruise ship
the summit has turned cornish coves into
lockdown zones
with locals already feeling the impact
it
shouldn't have been done now because of
covered and the fact
that they should have just held it on
zoom and did it that way
my business is shutting down thursday
friday saturday sunday it's not gonna
work
we'll pack up wednesday evening and then
we'll come back on monday
you uh give biden an ice cream if he
comes i would
yeah i'm boris yeah they're welcome
while there will be disruption for some
the summit is a sweet deal
the official g7 chocolate bar made in
the cornish town of wadebridge
had to get government approval got an
email first
just a out of the blue from one of the
offices in whitehall
they specified they wanted milk
chocolate flavoured with sea salt
covid and climate change are top of the
agenda here
both issues that impact this county the
leaders of some of the richest
countries in the world will be on this
beach at the weekend and it's thought
the summit will bring in around 50
million
pounds into cornwall the question is
just how much
real people living here will actually
see of that cash
camborne is 10 miles from the summit and
one of the poorest parts of cornwall
i think it's just a quick flashing pound
of money yeah
yeah we won't get nothing out of it i
don't think
cambodn and other places have got their
their problems
and i think the money could be better
spent
there are plenty of protests planned
this weekend
the eyes of the world on all of these
leaders
as they gather in this corner of
cornwall
oh let's speak to dan joining us from
falmouth good to see you dan
and i'm told something of a test already
for the police
[Music]
yeah absolutely uh police were alerted
this morning at
3 15 to a hotel uh not too far away from
where i'm stood in falmouth
the falmouth hotel and had to evacuate
it and put in a cordon it was after
a suspect package not on unusual events
um
for police certainly uh at big summits
like uh this but as i say it was a test
for police they had to evacuate two
hotels a number of people
staying in campervans they were only let
back into the hotel in the last half an
hour or so turns out the package
was safe although they do say it was a
hoax and that a criminal
investigation is underway so a test for
just some
of the six and a half thousand police
that are down in cornwall we are
just next to the media center behind me
here is the cruise ship which you
saw in my report there a fifth of those
police officers are staying on that
cruise ship which came in from estonia
uh last week because they're simply run
out of hotel rooms in cornwall an
accommodation
so instead they're on this luxury cruise
ship the spa
and seven restaurants i'm told are fully
uh closed
over here is the media center so this is
where the
thousand or so media who are accredited
will be coming and filing from
organizations
all around the world that opens at eight
o'clock uh this morning cornwall really
braced
uh for a pretty manic couple of days the
road closures importantly for the logos
kick in
uh from from today and that will cause
disruption as we heard people are
in some cases shutting up their
businesses the police hope that the
disruption
will be minimum for some they are
getting out of cornwall or shutting up
shop
dan many thanks indeed still to come on
the program the prime minister of course
meeting president biden ahead of the g7
summit in cornwall
and i've passed i'll be asking crete
cargill the shadow international
development secretary
what she's hoping to hear
the duke of edinburgh would have been
100s today the royal photographer arthur
edwards
will share his favorite photos prince
philip at quarter to eight
uh that big meeting between the
president and the pm can the two men
agree when to restart transatlantic
flights uh virginia messina
from the world travel and tourism
council will be here at 20 past
eight
the health secretary matt hancock is due
to give evidence this morning to a house
of commons committee
investigating the government's handling
of the pandemic what can we expect
let's ask our political correspondent
rob powell on deck in westminster
at morning rob well i suspect it's going
to be bruising to start with
yeah i think the second big act really
neil following uh that extraordinary
session of evidence from dominic
cummings former number 10 advisor a
couple of weeks ago
matt hancock will be speaking to the
same group of mps that dominic cummings
gave evidence to and you suspect a large
number of the questions
may well come off the back of some of
those extraordinary accusations that
dominic cummings made
he really i think amongst many targets
zeroed in on the health secretary
accused him of repeatedly lying saying
that he should have been fired
on a number of occasions um i think one
very important topic that you were
touching on just then with the trade
minister greg hans that will come up
is that question of care homes dominic
cummings
accused matt hancock of lying by saying
that he had promised that everyone that
went from a hospital into a care home
in march last year in the early stages
of the pandemic would be
tested and i think it's not just dominic
cummings and people like that putting
pressure on the health secretary over
this the last couple of weeks have seen
care providers
piling the pressure on as well more
revelations in the guardian
this morning with care providers saying
that they repeatedly warned the health
secretary about the dangers
of not testing i think the explanation
you'll hear from matt hancock
was that he said at the time that
everyone would be tested if possible
but of course testing capacity the
number of tests available was a lot
lower
back then so i think to an extent you'll
have a rehearsal of
some of the arguments we've heard over
the last fortnight i think what will
make today different though
is that the mps on this committee will
have a number of hours to dig into
detail with matt hancock
so they will be able to cross-examine
him in a way that's really different
from appearances in the house of commons
from even
interviews done on tv stations as well
and matt hancock is no shrinking violet
when it comes to these matters
so it could be lively kicks off at 9 30.
i'll be tuning in uh rob thanks very
much there will be
full coverage of that committee hearing
from half past
nine this morning here on sky news
also making the news this morning the
foreign secretary has criticized a
ruling by a russian court
declaring organizations linked to the
opposition leader alexey navalny as
extremist dominic ram described the
decision which stops any of mr navalny's
supporters from running for office as an
attack on those
standing up against corruption
lord ashcroft's daughter-in-law has been
granted bail over charges of
manslaughter in the death of a police
officer in belize
superintendent henry germick was found
shot dead on a dock last month
jasmine harton was charged the same day
regulators say that fertility clinics
must be clearer about their success
rates
and charges the competition and markets
authority has issued new guidance which
says that clinics will face legal action
if they don't provide a comparison of
their services with
other companies
and today marks the 95th birthday of one
of our great
children's literary characters winnie
the pooh a new cartoon shows pooh with
piglets christopher robin and friends
traveling to windsor castle to deliver a
present for the queen who
of course shares pooh's birthday
time to check and see how the weather's
looking
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
good morning there is more summer
weather to come
but it's a west east split western areas
will be somewhat cloudier we've got a
weather front
moving in from the atlantic and that
will bring more in the way of cloud
also a few spits and spots of rain quite
a lot of low cloud mr mark
around the coast especially for wales
and southwest england but eastern areas
so even eastern parts of ireland
northern ireland
and much of eastern britain that's where
we'll see the best of the sunshine today
so a mild start
and warm in that sunshine we're looking
at the high teens to the low to mid 20s
25 anywhere 26 even at places from hull
down towards london
strong sunshine though we called on to
the cloud a little bit further west and
we could see a few showers this
afternoon across the wheels but most
places should stay dry
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
kirsten thanks very much indeed coming
up i'll be asking the shadow secretary
of state for international development
crete cargill
just exactly what she's hoping to hear
from the g7 summit that's coming in just
a couple of minutes
[Music]
oh man i'm really really proud of it you
know a lot of people got locked down
puppies i i got a locked down novel um i
i actually
you know i owed my publishers a book and
um there was no excuse i was looking for
excuses
it's quite hard to write a novel but
once the first look down here i realized
there's no excuse i've got the time i've
got nothing
else to do so i really knuckled down and
got into it it's
uh you see it there on the screen now
it's um it's a book for
middle grade so you know sort of 10 to
13 year olds story about a 13 year old
kid with a very big mouth who
ends up finding that infamy is not
necessarily
all it's cracked up to be um he risks
his school place his friends his family
to go alone on a big adventure it's just
it's a straight-up comedy
i'm really proud of it i think it's the
best thing i've ever written to be
honest
i find it really really difficult you
know people who know me know you know i
act i do comedy music i like to do
short things jokes songs scenes
you know uh this long form stuff i find
it really difficult to
keep focusing on the same idea for so
long but i think the thing that
inspires me is kids man like kids i just
think are endlessly
interesting they're not as
i don't know adults sometimes feel a
little bit ruined as human beings
kids are just they're just great they're
so fresh imaginative creative
artistic and they deserve the best so i
think
i'm not going to undersell it i'm not
going to dumb it down i'm going to make
the best product
for kids that you can make that's the
thing that keeps me going i suppose and
i've also got my own kids who are
constantly like
that's not funny kids wouldn't say that
so that sort of supports me on
hello my name is nadja frantier
my name is ryan matthews i'm the marine
assistant
at rather a research station which is to
the west of the west
antarctic peninsula
[Music]
so far i've been here for five months
and it is an absolutely wonderful
experience
my name is fatima zazile the founder of
ikesa
from kuwait where we face many
environmental problems related to waste
pollution the frustration
and lack of information we are
collecting recyclables
from houses schools and businesses in
order to recycle them
in exchange you're recyclable to get a
tree
[Music]
welcome back the government says it's
hoping for a more pragmatic
approach from the eu to the brexit trade
negotiations
under the current terms of the northern
ireland protocol a ban on the trade of
sausage and processed meats will come
into force
if the uk and eu cannot agree new
regulatory standards
well in the last few minutes the trade
minister greg han said despite the
pressure
from the u.s president not to jeopardize
the northern ireland peace deal
he hopes an agreement could be reached
the us has played a big big role in the
good friday group we absolutely agree
that preserving the peace in northern
ireland but to do that
does need a more pragmatic approach for
the european union
in terms of how it interprets uh the
protocol and those what the talks
yesterday uh between lord frost and mary
schefter which were all about
was making sure that the protocol can
work better to preserve the peace in
northern ireland
let's speak now to shadow international
development secretary preet cargill good
to see you this morning um
and a busy few days for politicians
particularly those in
government what do you want to see
emerge from the g7 summit taking place
in cuomo
well as you said president biden is
going to be meeting with boris johnson i
think this is really an opportunity for
the prime minister
to get back on the front foot and we
rebuild what is termed as a special
relationship
with the united states and i think the
prime minister should have three clear
prior
priorities and the first he's got to
really make a cast iron guarantee
um of the uk government's continued
commitment to the good friday agreement
as you've heard i know this is going to
be something very important
for president biden and secondly he's
really got to
end the sort of attempt that we've seen
from the chancellor to water down
global tax reforms we've seen the
ambition from
president biden and the g7 countries and
it's a shame that
we haven't been at the forefront of
wanting a global fair attack system and
thirdly
i think you know he's got to reverse his
aid cuts there's been criticisms
from all corners of the world including
the biden administration and
the us congress because we know that
this is signaling a retreat in the year
that the government is going to be
tested on its leadership
on the g7 on the global partnership for
education and cop 26.
it's really important that it it
maintains its own credibility
and i think these are going to be some
really um interesting negotiations at
the g7 summit
but but just in terms of the good friday
agreement indeed that the effect that
the northern ireland protocol and our
government's actions may well have on it
do you share any of the frustration of
government ministers
that sausages sausages produced in this
country since time immemorial should
somehow
not be seen as fit for moving from great
britain to northern ireland
well i think you know it's obvious that
the collapse of trust in the prima
in the prime minister across many of the
communities in northern ireland is
really a result
of him promising communities that they
would he would not be placing any
barriers
down the irish scene what we've actually
seen is the opposite
he's got to find practical solutions
that's what being in government and
being in leadership
is he's got to reduce that sort of
friction down the irish
which has been caused by the protocol um
one-fifths of all
border eu checks are now carried out in
northern ireland you know
we've really got to find solutions both
sides have got to
be willing to come to the table and
compromise and i think that's what
president biden
surely will be pushing um prime minister
johnson to do
but but in what way is it not hyperbolic
to suggest that moving sausages from
great britain to northern ireland
somehow risks the peace that that exists
there
well i think it's it's as a result of as
i've already said the
deal that the government negotiated and
i thought that you know they obviously
thought that they had a ready deal
and that this could be changed at any
point it isn't going to be difficult but
i think you know on both sides
what we've got to see is practical
solutions how do we overcome
the issues that northern ireland um that
the government has created in northern
ireland because it hasn't been offering
practical solutions it hasn't been
really understanding the level of
feeling um across northern ireland i
think it's really really important that
we find the solutions
unfortunately talks haven't been
positive as we saw yesterday
and really what we need to see from the
government is practical solutions
i i mean the word of the interview with
between myself and greg hans
was pragmatic practical appears to be
yours what is the practical pragmatic
solution to all of this
well you've got to have civic society
business leaders and political leaders
all part of that consultation on the
northern ireland protocol
feeling that they've actually got to say
and that they are being listened to
and being heard that's what leadership
is about it's about bringing people
together
being able to resolve those issues
they're not going to be easy i
appreciate that that means that both
sides are going to have to have
um some compromises but this is what you
would expect from our prime minister is
actually to bring both sides together
and to find those practical solutions
especially ahead of the g7 summit
when it knows that this is an important
issue for president biden and he would
want us to seek to resolve this
pete corgill good to see you this
morning thanks for being with us
so the first major announcement ahead of
the g7 summit
is america's pledge to provide half a
billion vaccines for the world's poorer
nations
and our africa correspondent has seen
evidence of just why it is
so badly needed more than 2 billion
vaccine doses have now been administered
across the world the g7 alone accounts
for over 556 million of those more than
a quarter
leaders have already agreed to commit
more than 7 billion pounds to fund an
increase in tests
treatments and vaccines around the world
but that still leaves the world health
organizations program
with a shortfall of more than 16 billion
pounds
africa has had the slowest roll out of
any continent
with less than two percent of the
population vaccinated
many countries are reliant on the kovacs
scheme for supplies which
have been hit by delays in india one of
the countries and most desperate needs
of more vaccines
is lesotho as john sparks reports
[Applause]
behind the doors in an old corrugated
hangar
we found medics and mechanics and a
mountain pilot
saying a little prayer for their mission
is
testing and their responsibilities great
millions of people are counting on them
this is a mobile clinic with a doctor
and a nurse
who provide health care in the kingdom
of lesotho
a mountainous territory which sits on
the roof
of southern africa and they've been
given a critical task
they must deliver covert 19 vaccines
to the nation
but there is a terrible shortage here
and we have to fly 200 kilometers
to pick up a couple of dozen jabs
how many doses do you have for now we
are having
30 dollars 30. yes how many doses are
you going to need in total
then in total we will need
let me estimate uh 2 million doses
2 million dollars to be at the secure
site
the fact is the vast majority in lesotho
are waiting
for a vaccine tells you something about
how
how precious they are for sure yeah
definitely there might be a lot of these
being made but like having them here
you know that the process to get them
here has just been so long and
detailed that does make them precious
we flew on to a place called cubanani
where key health workers
and vulnerable adults have not been
protected
and the pilot put us down on the
mountainside
our special cargo was handed over to a
nurse
but it won't go far in a district of 10
000
people how many people have been
vaccinated here
so far so far 73
73 people yes mostly the
the village health workers and the
health center committee and some of
our colleagues here staff members okay
yes you're gonna need a lot more
especially for the
for the people here yes
it is an isolated spot but the message
has gone out
about covet 19 as a third wave of
infection in africa
takes root and we watched as they began
to congregate
why do you want to get a covert vaccine
geek
[Laughter]
do you think the virus could come here
to the mountains
they were gathered in a room warmed up
by the sun
and given the first of a two dose
vaccine
and the recipients said they were
grateful
[Music]
are you one of the lucky people the
fortunate people
the supply of vaccines in africa has
almost ground to a halt
with the world health organization
pleading with rich countries
to donate their stocks in some countries
they're
talking about vaccinating children now
here you're still vaccinating
health workers i wonder how do you feel
about that
hey we are not comfortable yes it's not
fair at all it's just to be rolled out
as quickly as possible because this
pandemic is killing people
the kingdom in the mountains has been
left behind in the race to vaccinate the
public
but as this shape-shifting virus
encircles the world
lesotho should be everybody's
responsibility
john sparks sky news in cuban yani
coming up next you're on breakfast the
duke of edinburgh would have been
100 years old today we'll be looking at
the best photos of prince philip as
chosen
by the sun's royal photographer arthur
edwards joining us next
[Music]
our job is to tell the truth this is a
forgotten front line
they are dying here
[Music]
boys we've got some interesting ways of
showing you what's going on their
message to us
get ready instructing you to stay at
home
i can't believe we did that it's pretty
special isn't it
they have breached the road there is a
lot of
gas being fired all around
[Music]
it is an absolute carnival kind of
atmosphere out here for prime minister
modern decisive degree
these students and now they're going to
be arrested
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
[Applause]
the roads have been inundated the only
way out
is to get people by boat
what is fear that over 200 people might
have died because of these landslides
[Music]
this on any given day would have been
bustling with people but today
it's absolutely deserted
this is one of the most sensitive areas
of of northeast delhi where there's been
clashes
i'm never lazarus and i'm skies reporter
based in delhi
[Music]
hello my name is nadja frantier
my name is ryan matthews i'm the marine
assistant
at rather research station which is to
the west of the west antarctic peninsula
so far i've been here for five months
and it is an absolutely wonderful
experience
did you know symptoms of hay fever can
develop at any stage of life
not just in childhood the pollen reports
sponsored by philips connected air
purifiers
it's a cloudy and mild start across the
uk and
ireland but the cloud will tend to break
especially in the east
to reveal warm spells of sunshine and
temperatures
widely into the low 20s maybe peaking at
around 26
celsius further north and west though we
do tend to hang on quite a lot of cloud
and
a little bit of light and patchy rain
it's certainly breezier and cooler in
the far northwest
it could be the odd shower today across
england and wales but most places
i think will escape them now we are
looking at a high grass pollen risk
across
central and southern areas staying low
in the north until the middle of
june and around 95 percent of fever
sufferers are allergic to grass pollen
and its grass and weed pollen that are
going to be the main issues at the
moment
as the peak season approaches
the pollen reports sponsored by philips
connected air purifiers
today would have been the duke of
edinburgh's 100th birthday it is just
two months since he died and the queen
has marked the occasion by planting a
rose
named after him the prince's
philanthropic work is also to be
remembered with the duke of edinburgh
awards scheme
launching its biggest ever fundraising
challenge as our royal correspondent
rhiannon mills reports
in the gardens at windsor where they
enjoyed so much time together
the queen had come out to see a tribute
to her husband
each rose there's a donation that goes
to
the uh living legacy fund which will
help more children
uh engage as well so it's a beautiful
flower in itself a double flower it
looks lovely
um right now with a cold spring and it
all being a
nature being a little bit behind it
doesn't look so lovely there but that's
what it looks like so
the picture says it all well that's
really fun
it's just nine weeks since prince philip
died at the castle
before his death the palace had
discussed plans to mark his centenary
but even when he was alive it was always
going to be low-key
in the way that he wanted the duke of
edinburgh was never much
interested in birthdays still less being
a hundred in fact
he didn't even want to live that long
and yet after he died
we've started this process of reflecting
on his contribution
and very much as when queen victoria's
husband the prince consort died in 1861
the nation is discovering that in fact
prince philip did a great deal more
than people realized like the duke of
edinburgh award
their living legacy fund set up after
the duke's death
has so far raised half a million pounds
and to keep the momentum going they're
asking everyone not just
young people to take on their do it for
youth challenge
doing sonobar is one of their youth
ambassadors aiming to run a half
marathon as part of her challenge she
met
prince philip i have so much gratitude
for what he's done for him creating the
scheme
the scheme has been such a great thing
not just for myself but for millions of
young people across the country
even across the world covid meant that
crowds were asked to stay away
on the day of his funeral but this
summer at windsor
and at the palace of hollywood house
there is a chance for people to come
and remember him with exhibitions
commemorating the part that prince
philip played in the coronation
his love of art his career in the navy
and showing some of the unusual gifts he
received as britain's longest serving
consort
since his death the queen has carried on
with her duties
in the way that he would have wanted
it's these regimental things
for the alliums forever surrounded by
reminders
of her beloved husband rhiannon mills
sky news
a couple of days uh other stories now
the drug company pfizer
says it will donate 500 million doses of
covered vaccine to the u.s government
on a not-for-profit basis it follows a
commitment from president biden
that the u.s will give vaccines to
approximately 100
low-income countries
around 360 000 people who lost their
jobs during lockdown
are still unemployed according to a new
study citizen's advice says its findings
show that changes are needed to
universal credit
to stop those most affected by the
pandemic being
left behind
the british board of film classification
says parents are
increasingly concerned about the amount
of swearing in films
it says adults don't want to see
offensive language too often
because they're worried their children
will hear
uh let's reflect on the political
developments of the day our political
correspondent rob powell
uh joining us once again from
westminster rob as always good to see
you two different topics i think we need
to discuss
uh mr hancock and of course the g7 let's
let's start with the former
and what could be a pretty bruising
encounter with the select committee for
the health secretary
yeah i think so we don't quite know how
long uh matt hancock's appearance in
front of the joint health and science
select committee uh will last but
remember don when dominic cummings sat
in front of the same mps what a
fortnight ago
he was there for seven hours and it was
an extraordinary session i think
it seems unlikely perhaps that matt
hancock will be there for quite as long
as that
but the mps will get i think a number of
hours
to go over in detail mr hancock's
record throughout this pandemic and i
think you can expect
some of those revelations from dominic
cummings to be put to him
as well clearly chief among them will be
this question
over care homes and whether matt hancock
did indeed promise
uh that all patients covered patients
being moved from hospitals into care
homes at the beginning of the pandemic
would be tested that is what dominic
cummings says the health secretary
promised
um he says that was one of a number of
lies as he sees it
that matt hancock made and says that he
should have been fired for it i think
what we will hear from the health
secretary
is that he essentially promised to use
his best efforts to test as many people
as possible
but there simply weren't enough uh tests
at the time
um to go around i think judging by some
of the interviews mr hancock's given
since then i remember a doorstep
interview on the day that dominic
cummings gave his evidence
i don't think there is clearly any love
lost between the two men
and matt hancock when he is pushed when
he is pressed
is someone that often comes out swinging
so i think when some of the more
inflammatory
accusations from mr cummings are put to
mr hancock
you can expect a fairly fiery response
the g7 then briefly uh shall we uh and
of course there will be lots of bonomi
lots of fine words and
plenty of talk of this atlantic treaty
but in the margins we do understand that
the united states is putting
some significant pressure on the uk to
sort out the situation
as regards the northern ireland border
yeah absolutely brexit
the sort of specter haunting another big
international
gathering and the question of what is
happening um with the northern ireland
protocol that mechanism
to ensure that the land border on the
island of ireland
stays open what we have heard in the
last 24 hours is concern coming from the
u.s side
the u.s national security adviser saying
that the their side does
have concerns over what this means
for peace on northern ireland we know
that joe biden
takes his irish ancestry and his irish
roots very
seriously um so it is likely i think to
be something that is talked about
um in cornwall it may be something very
likely to be something that is brought
up when boris johnson meets joe biden in
cornwall
later today i don't think we should
overstate this necessarily though
important though as it is and yes joe
biden clearly will take this very very
seriously
there are other very very big issues
that need to be discussed
and i think the whole um drama the whole
sort of
choreography of the day is meant to be
western democracies
coming together to say the us is back
and i don't think the u.s or the uk will
want anything even brexit to get in the
way of that
good thanks rob and of course that uh
committee hearing we were just
mentioning you can watch that from half
past nine
here on sky news
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning we have more sunshine to
come in fact it could be a
very nice weekend if you like the hot
sunshine that
is a little bit grey this morning across
many western areas but it's a mild start
today
and the cloud will thin and break a
little bit as we go through the weekend
i'll just
zoom right back to the beginning there
the graphic is going a little bit skippy
and all this heat
got the cloud in the west with some rain
and drizzled a little bit more
persistent in the far northwest of
scotland but
generally speaking it's we're looking at
a few showers perhaps across england
wales as we go
through the day today i think most
places will manage to escape them so
west east split with the weather a bit
more cloud for windward western coast
eastern airs the warm sunshine up to 26
maybe even 27 degrees so feeling very
warm indeed
just watch out for the auto shower
the weather sponsored by qatar airways